The people fighting each
other over stupid shit,
then you're not going to take the time
to sit back. I compare those people,
you know, was really going on. I,
I used the analogy of a magician.
They're trying to tell you,
look what's in the left hand,
but what the real shit
is in the right hand.
So by doing all this shit and
causing all these problems,
you're not going to go back and look at
the shit that he's pushing through his
agendas. He just cut a taxes
to the fucking enriches,
uh, people that, uh, the
billionaires and corporations,
which he said he wasn't going to do.
He's gone back on everything.
So if he could just get people,
fuck you and fuck you,
and getting people to hate each other and
keep this country is the United States
of America. When the fuck, how
did we become United as a country?
Like I think a lot of these countries
right now who may pose a threat or
whatever, they're seeing what the
fuck's going on and they're like, Yo,
this country's never been
more fucking divided.
It's divided states of America,
not the United States of America.
Well,
what he's doing with these,
these rallies is he's getting people
excited about being a part of a team and a
team that's winning.
You know,
like we're the team that's kicking ass
and this is team fake news or there you
tell them to go fuck themselves
and everybody gets Ya, Ya, Ya.
He's consolidating his support.
He,
and it doesn't have to make sense and
especially it doesn't have to make sense
with the people that are going to these
rallies because they're not smart people
in the first place.
There are people that are easily led,
but that's the same thing with people
that would go to the rallies for Hillary
Clinton or people who go to the
rallies for almost all these people,
a giant chunk of them are just, they're
just lemmings. I don't know what to do.
I do and hit one thing and that was
when fucking Hillary Clinton Clinton was
losing and the faces of the crying and
people who were like fucking losing
negotiate when Trump won.
I was like, I'm sorry,
but like funny fucking dude.
If that's dead,
the fucking truth of your existence
that you put every fucking ounce or your
shit into this fucking
corrupt as politician,
whether it's fucking Hillary Clinton or
fucking Bernie Sanders on any of them.
I feel fucking sorry for you.
I was laughing at those people when she
lost and they were losing their shit on
TV. Like they were just
fucking stunned at how like,
cause you don't realize I travel through
America and people may be progressive
on the outskirts,
but go into the middle of this
motherfuck and see what you got.
What the fuck is that?
Voted for that too. Yeah.
Well there was also people
realize that she was corrupt.
I mean you did a good job of calling
her corrupt Hillary. Absolutely.
He just kept up with the mantra was going,
he loves mantras and he pushes those
fucking, but they just had yes.
Yeah, correct. So crazy.
Bernie crazy burns. Yeah.
I mean he's, he's a, he's a good
manipulator in that sense, but
she, no, she didn't do any service,
but there was also like a lot of the
women that were really upset, we're like,
this guy was in that video saying you
take girls and grab them by the Pussy.
And so they,
they felt like this was going to give
man a license to be sexually abusive.
And I think that in a lot of ways is what
like started the ball rolling with the
me too movement. It wasn't just the
exposing of monsters like Bill Cosby,
but it was also the fact
that you're dealing with this
guy who gets in the White
House. That's clearly not what
you want. You want. If it's a man,
you want a man who respects women,
who's a statesman,
who's a person who has worked
their life to get to that position.
Not a person who did it as an
afterthought once they're already famous.
See like the difference between a guy
like Obama, like Obama's probably,
he's probably measured his words ever
since he was in college because he was
hoping one day he would be president.
Whereas a guy like Donald Trump's just
been banging hoes and fucking fly around
the jet with his name on it since the
80s I mean this is what the guy did.
So then once he's in
office, people like, no,
just couldn't believe like
how could this have happened?
This is the pussy grabber.
He's not supposed to be in
there. And I get their pain.
I understand it and it is also funny,
but there's something like the
woman's on her knees with the glasses.
You ever seen that check with the DA
on screaming? She's like, she's a meme.
He loves, she, she, she will
exist forever. They made a,
they call it Trump derangement syndrome
now because people are literally,
they're so angry that he is in power and
there's nothing they can do about it.
But the problem is that anger and that
that going derange that that empowers the
people that support him.
They don't understand when
you're on your knees screaming,
fuck the people on the other side that
the Trump supporters of their fucking red
hats on, they think that's hilarious.
And they look, this is the liberal left,
unhinged, detached from
reality. Meanwhile,
we're making America great again and
black unemployment is at an all time low
and you know it's,
it's weird time for the truth because
there's so many people that don't want to
go any further past the surface.
The truth is this guy figured
out a way to win a rigged system.
He did.
He figured out a way or when a rig system
by pretending to be a republican guy
was a democrat his whole life democratic
supporters his whole life figured out a
way. Oh just pick a, be a
republican. They're easier
to scam. Weaseled his way in,
figured out a way. This whole
make America great again. Yeah.
Rah Rah Rah called people a bunch of
stupid shit campaign like a motherfucker.
Take Diet pills,
keep that energy high.
Just travel all across the country doing
these rallies and one and one a system
that really shouldn't be there to win.
And I think that we need a better way
to run our government and your idea is
fucking genius. An Alpha male or
Alpha female, that one person,
the one at the top of the peak run 300
million people's insane running 300
people's insane. If 300 people,
one person running shit,
you're going to have disagreements.
You're going to have people that are
upset that this one person gets to dictate
for the next four to eight years.
The path of everyone in this group and
your financial future, your healthcare,
you're,
you're all these how much taxes you pay,
all depending on what dip shit wins. The
popularity contest. That's outrageous.
It's an archaic way of handling things.
It's just not necessary.
But the problem with letting everybody
vote too is that people are really easily
manipulated and they're
really undereducated people.
They don't have any incentive to pay
attention to the real issues and what's at
stake and what the
consequences of each vote are.
They just vote with whatever feels good
and they're busy and people are tired
cause they're eating shitty food and then
not exercising and they're working all
day in a job that sucks. And
they come home, their wives,
bitch Nadam and they're on antidepressants
and pills and then the kids are all
fucked up and they don't have the time.
They don't have the time.
And they don't have the,
the incentive to be enlightened.
They don't have the incentive to have it.
A objective in lightened approach to how
you handle the future of our society.